[Music]
happy birthday you're not special you
can't know
hey everybody its Michael cost and the
worst birthday podcast thank you so much
for listening thanks for pressing play
we have another great episode this week
as we do every Thursday on the all
things comedy network to listen to every
worst birthday episode that's ever
happened visit worst birthday com
you can also listen on itunes on
soundcloud on stitcher please leave a
rating in a review we sure do love that
leave your Twitter handle in there and
I'll make sure to tweet to you and thank
you personally because it goes a long
way before we get to this week's guest
who is the wonderfully hilarious
stand-up comedian podcaster she has two
podcasts one's very popular called the
dork forest the other one she just
started doing with Laurie Kilmartin
who's a writer and comedian before we
get into this week's episode with Jackie
Kashian let me just plug a couple things
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday
and Sunday night I will be at the funny
bone in st. Louis Missouri
I want to thank juniors last laugh in
Erie Pennsylvania for having me last
week not a lot of people in Los Angeles
we're excited to board a flight to
Pennsylvania the day after the national
election but I was because it was fun to
perform in Pennsylvania it was fun to
talk to the two Trump supporters some
Trump supporters a lot not everyone and
here in Pennsylvania was but I enjoyed
it I had a great time
and we need to talk to each other a bit
more and we need to listen a bit more ok
everybody it sucks listening but let's
just listen to each other man the people
on the left are screaming and the people
on the right are screaming and what
needs to happen is we need to whisper
but we need to listen wouldn't that be
nice this is even a political podcast it
isn't so please go to worst birth date
calm if you're an Amazon shopper go to
our website worst birthday calm click on
the amazon banner
do your shopping on Amazon that way and
we get a little kickback which helps us
with our podcast costs as always you can
email me any questions or concerns about
the podcast or comedy or life in general
at Michael at Michael Kosta comm I will
be at the st. Louis funnybone this
weekend to find all my live dates at
Michael Kosta calm I will be New Year's
Eve in Washington DC so that's exciting
me and president-elect Trump can hang
out I'll invite them to my show and I'll
listen to him and he can listen to me
it's all about listening okay let's get
to Jackie Kashian this is her worst
birthday episode thanks again for
listening you can visit Jackie Kashian
dot-com you can also find her on Twitter
at Jackie Kashian I hope you enjoyed
this episode I will be back again next
Thursday Thanksgiving
holy [ __ ] out of that happen with a new
episode thanks for listening the worst
birthday podcast I'm Michael Costa hope
you have a shitty birthday everybody no
I don't know I I don't think I've ever
added it one time somebody said my mom
and she has both of those but doesn't
want to know that we think that's jack
occasionally yeah we wouldn't have it I
wouldn't I wouldn't add a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
thing that we edited was somebody told a
long story about how much they hated
their boyfriend oh and with them well no
they were broken up but then things got
better with that person and they were
like can we just blank out the name and
I got a respect it's nice of you to do
that because here's the thing yeah you
have a long story about how much you
hate somebody you shouldn't be with that
person that's exactly gram ocation over
here yeah no I think that's right but
you know I I had this discussion with
Ari Shaffir how personal are we because
he wants full names you know the phone
numbers he's just [ __ ] at all I don't
know what tell me about Europe your many
podcasts my yes go completely person
entirely introduced me about a month ago
as someone who does a lot of charity
work she has two podcasts I was like
that is right funny
yeah that's funny the the I dork forest
you've been doing for how long this is
the 11th year holy [ __ ] ground for
podcasting you guys I really there's no
money in it yeah but man that is that is
right uh you were on the I was on the
tip of it I was on the tip of it heard
about it at an open mic and some guy was
talking about podcasting and I said what
is that he said this great website you
could just call in oh my and they record
it they upload it to iTunes and it's
done and I said well that sounds
idiot-proof and he would fault you would
use your home phone and call in that's
it oh my gosh
right 2006 yeah for a long time I
thought it was 2005 but it turns out it
was wishful thinking to have beaten a
jimmy pardo but he was first
yeah he's three months before me and so
you would what was the first step is it
still up the first up the first episode
is up that what I have is if you go to
dark forest calm yes there's because
they were phone calls yeah it's it was
reviewed as sounding like it was
reviewed on this podcast thing is
sounding like someone held a phone up to
AM radio yeah and that is exactly what
it sound like but if you if you go to
dork force comm it says pre I think pre
pre recorded like our slippery something
it says archived are 213 episodes
Wow that are pre that and then I'm
pushing on like 400 episodes here I'm
just dork force calm then I just started
in the last year I know this is ones
where I charge people Oh dork forest
okay
yeah Bandcamp page because live episodes
they always cost me at least 20 bucks
right sure often hundreds of dollars yes
gonna say it's a space you got the chair
I can make 40 bucks unbanned camp
knock yourself I think you should mm-hm
I've been pushing this this stupid
amazon banner alright I make money on my
house and so I don't make any money but
I'm just I'm trying to reiterate do it I
just started okay I mean I'm gonna take
a couple months I've made like 12 bucks
something but what I'm sure what I'm
trying to reiterate to the listeners is
like no one's getting rich here folks
oh this is for lies web hosting right
this is free content and and hopefully
an idea that you should come and see my
stand-up correct
so I I'm advertising but I'm also trying
to give you some entertainment and so
we're in this together so if you have a
hundred bucks throw it throw it throw it
at the donation button or for free go to
the amazon banner which is just a portal
from your website
there we go amazon you order normal and
then use graze the show gets a little
bit of a kick that's crazy it's all
thing Jackie knows what she's doing
you always know what you're doing I feel
like I met you late in the stand-up game
and my thing I think I've been doing it
forever yeah how long you been in I've
been doing it 13 years but we knew we
knew each other before Bridgetown last
year but last year I felt like I really
got the hang yeah and I got to hear your
bow and arrow joke a few times which I
just love that's it's weird it's gonna
go in it's gonna go on the new album
recording in December yeah that is a
funny and and and I mean weird in a
positive way it's like I'm laughing
going why is she talking about a bow and
arrow right now because I was given a
bone somebody loves me yeah that's great
for Christmas when is your birthday my
birthday is July 20th July 20th 1965
oh you had to do the year you do the
year does the year you know why cuz we
live in Los Angeles California no but
I'm on this other podcast with Laurie
Kilmartin you know and we were born four
days apart from each other that's cool
and she keeps telling people how old we
are
I'm like it's I guess it's out that
everyone knows now so [ __ ] a it's
funny when you go to other cities around
the country and I'll say to someone hey
is it you is it cool if I ask you your
age and they look at you like you're
crazy like yeah we're allowed to share
ages but I'm just so used to that you're
not supposed to say how old are you or
people say 30s right somebody what's
that [ __ ] does that mean not not less
than one year ago I had a meeting and
this woman was like I'm sure you're 37
and I said you are very polite you have
no sense of aging right this is being
great and I'm like 35 pounds over so it
fills in a lot of crowd there we go so
but it's nice it's but there's nothing I
can do about my age okay do you have
children
I do not okay are you able to see a
child and know their age
I'm pretty good cuz I had a dozen nieces
on it so that's good you have practice
yeah I will say to a parent like how old
how old is Tim is eighty-nine and Tim is
three but if you don't have kids you'd
have any idea where there's there's no
perspective there's no way with it yeah
what we're birthdays like for you and
your and your family and your home and
your life not good they weren't no no
they were first of all I'm the youngest
of six ah nobody cared for a long time
yeah and then my mother died okay and I
didn't kill her it's not my fault you're
familiar with the Irish goodbye right is
when your mom kills herself in a drunk
driving accident is that what happened
to you yes oh [ __ ]
no you're supposed to yeah well because
the Irish good because I wasn't over it
it turns out right yeah it's not too
soon
well there's there's something I read
about you that made me laugh many years
ago and did did your father recently
pass no no my stepmother passed your
stepmother pass my dad got sick he
almost died and was certain he was gonna
die because he never gets ill right cuz
none of us do because this is peasant
stuff Yeah right you don't get sick you
live a miserable life forever this my
job and now you get to hear it yeah as
this was genetically constructed to pick
up a rock on someone else's property
perfect yeah but I read I forget where
it was and is that this is dark but but
we're gonna go there
it was right after the Colorado movie
theater shooting my stepmother okay so
this is that's what I reckon a funny
interview it's a hilarious you want to
share it you should you know what I'm
talking about
I know it's okay and I got a bit out of
it yeah because I realized at that
moment that comics were just a parade of
Asperger's crimes so uh my mother my
stepmother who raised me from when I was
eight okay until approximately four
years ago yeah
passed away right uh the same week as
the shooting at the Batman movie correct
and so I come back from the funeral I go
up to a bunch of comics one of whom I
know pretty well and it was like how's
it going I was like it's a sad I just
came from my mom's birthday my mom's
birthday no I'm not her birthday right
her the opposite but right her funeral
yeah and one of the other comics who I
do not know so well who is
genuinely very funny yeah said Oh was
she at that Batman movie I mean it's
just funny that's just I could not stop
laughing but at the time I did say hey
captain as burgers yeah you're not good
at this
yeah that's that I I think that story
sticks with me because people people who
don't know comics would find that beyond
offensive terrible and dark and within
the comedy community that is kind of how
we say I care about you right there's
there was something yeah he was like hey
alright then when we try to make you
laugh at this weird guy I did horrible
and it did yeah and my mother would have
laughs my stepmother would have thought
that was hilarious that's because she
was pretty dark herself so so youngest
of six so birthdays yeah that's a big
deal
nobody even my father to this day says
yeah it's not your birthday your
birthday was that one day well I agree
with that
sure that is the birthday that is the
day of birth and we're celebrating the
anniversary of that birth exactly but if
you don't call him on his birthday oh so
sad too bad yeah I called him a couple
of years ago and he said you know I
spent the day with your brother Russ he
did not mention my birthday all day long
it Russ and I said hey Dad when's
Russell [ __ ] and there was some silence
my father's what I love about him he
goes good point good point taken
what is your father's birthday sometime
in either March or May great yeah so I
think March so was there a family like I
mean when you say you guys didn't
celebrate it was an acknowledged even or
was there like it was sort of a dessert
or what well the weird thing is my
stepmother came into our lives when I
was seven or eight and she started doing
birthdays cool she was like birthdays
are a big deal we're gonna do birthdays
so for the first for like three years I
had amazing birthday she baked a cake
she made dinner there was you you got to
pick what the meal was isn't that a fun
thing it was a fun thing was how my
family did it was like cantaloupe fried
shrimp and chocolate pudding and it's
life it just has to have in there and so
that's essentially what she did and she
did it for I think it had to be four
maybe I will she was still alive
because I can't remember when she
stopped doing it but it was like three
or four years I think I was 10 or 11
it's a lot of kids and a lot a lot of
brain magical meals right right and I
she liked me a lot good I was pretty
psyched about the others because I
always wanted the toys on the cake so I
always insisted on a purchase like the
little little characters I got cowboys
and Indians one year cuz of course I've
always wanted moccasins you have and so
I got so I got to play with those toys
when they were done after they'd been
washed of course sure and but my brother
Phil always wanted a strawberry a
strawberry whipped cream cake hmm and
his birthday was in July 4th ok and this
was in the 70s pre air-conditioning
everywhere where did you grow up little
town little factory town outside of
Milwaukee called
sophomore kids Mike Cudahy okay so so
how many July birthdays were the
siblings seems to so far we got two
that's two and then and then my brothers
we could always remember my brother
Phil's birthday because it was fourth of
July that's easy and Erica's birthday
merit and Phil so Phil's birthday and my
also that my dad used to tell him look I
put this parade on for you it's good
time I like your dad I don't even know
him but I like this guy everybody likes
everybody
it was somebody said to me not long ago
and nobody said this to me sure but this
is the bit Michael right I'm gonna do
the bit Michael it's but I actually cuz
I can't talk to my dad about politics
he's a salesman and he's a button-pusher
okay and so you can't go straight
forward at that guy you can't just say
hey what do you think about this because
you're gonna get some sarcasm and he's
gonna try to get a rise out of him and
so I had to go sideways and so I told
him that someone compared him to Donald
Trump the other night at a show sure and
there was a silence and I was like yeah
I almost punched a guy in the face debt
because the thing about you is that what
we know about you is I know you're a
good guy because none of your sons are
creeps right and that is kind of true
you can tell a lot you can tell a lot by
one kid can go bad and that sure your
fault sure you
six kids was anybody surprised with
Billy Bush you know like I mean I I've
worked with Billy Bush a couple times
and I was remember walking away being
like I seem a little off surprise that
he was a little bit creepy I don't know
he looks creepy looks like a frickin
elbow squeezer yes he does yes yes yeah
ladies one of these is like hey nice to
meet you and then they grab your hand
you can't leave and then they freaking
Maul your your elbow like it's their
scrotum yeah and you want to just make
him stop touching I had a friend in
college that would be very handsy with
ladies and I know it's not okay and I in
cold call that's what it is as a man I
didn't know what to [ __ ] do and it
made me feel uncomfortable but I you
know but it was it was uncommon if he
was touching me right if he was actually
touching you there's there's a couple of
different responses there's there's
there's ways to deal with it um you know
and you sort of learn to just stay out
of a grab and race yes don't eight feet
away from all people in all time gonna
need more than an arm's length um that
guy that's I there was a comic in
Minneapolis who I was like okay I'm
gonna use you as a pick with this dude
sometimes yeah and he was a good sport
he was always like oh that's too bad
that that even has to happen yes
98% of the men on the planet decent
human being yep 2% it's nice to hear
that 12 it's nice to hear that the 98%
of Aaron and I 98% yeah that's also the
other thing is you can't say you're in
the 98% that makes you the 2% if you're
saying that so I'm fascinated by big
family because I'm from youngest of four
but we didn't we were yeah we did we did
birthdays there was a baby was the meal
and all that yeah but I don't always
come from the same place of pain that
some a lot some comics come from mm-hmm
but six kids is a lot it's a lot I wish
adds to it sure Armenian Armenian half
Irish okay and so what are those
cultures birthdays traditions there's a
lot of uh if you're a boy it's a good
idea if it's a girl there's a there's a
little more step and fetch it but it's
but that's that's and that's fine I
don't
I have only like I've always been a
feminist and I've always been all
political sure the last
two years have made me more conscious in
the last eight years of baby more
conscious of race sure than I've ever
been in my life sure
so if I pepper my entire conversation
with like feminism and racism I am sorry
it's okay I am newly woke my friend I
want I want what's in your brain right
now which is right yeah which will be
what it is so but it's we did that we
had with pretty good birthdays but when
I remember going to college yeah
Andrew swear which was at the university
wisconsin-madison funds place I'm good
great uh a comedy club Great Lakes
that's where I start I started stand-up
there did you put in 84 okay so the
owner of it no Gus owned the building
god it's crazy it's hilarious yeah and
but he owns the whole city that guy he
owns almost the entirety of states right
yeah Sam Kinison um his brother bill
Kinnison owned the club he was I didn't
know that yeah
Tahoe that's cool that's good knowledge
it's a it's a weird it's a great
Hollywood kind of Creepo story a lot of
1984 things happening yeah with the
Kinison boys and so but the the you were
in college I mean so I go to college
previously you know my birthday would
come around and Nancy my stepmother
would make sure everybody would she
would call everybody on their birthday
and make sure everybody knew mhm I go to
college uh that first summer I think I
lived at home so it was fine mhm
the next summer I lived in Madison I
lived in in in the college town sure and
every year after that no one called me
on my birthday
weird right it was my sister and I made
a pact that we had to call each other on
our birthdays because we started meeting
or the rest of the world they do and
Facebook is made of kind of [ __ ] oh
but but now you'll read it now you know
everyone my brother's call me on my
birthday now it's kind of nice yeah and
even even my dad called me up a couple
of days ago he's hey it's uh Terry's
birthday coming up here and I was like
you're their dad or nothing and he's
like just just cut me something here
yeah just help me out I was like yeah
it's tomorrow when
well how many siblings have July just me
and fill in fill of July Scott his
kitchen kitchen kitchen yes that does
have a kitchen early 70s what no I said
Scott that's a Christmas December 23rd
Wow right around the holidays here and
then Phil's July 4th yeah right and then
then the my sister September 27th that's
my birthday
what's it what's your sister's name Oh
Darla hiya Darla I know she listens
so Darla September 27th and then what's
left is Russ Russ it goes because
there's me I know I know Darla Russ
Scott Phil Phil and Terry I don't think
okay Terry yeah Tarek no Scots Christmas
so Scott Russ are harder wait Phil
Terry and Russ are harder Terry is
either March or May and then Russ is
March or May and when my dad is March or
Bay perfect so it's all like that so
it's what would they I'm I'm as casual
about birthdays as the I mean I know
there's not the hero of this story I
don't know what anybody's but this I'm
not I'm not trying to put you in the
spot but this is what fascinates me
about birthdays is that it really does
get into the brain of one's own
personality how we decide to celebrate
these things some people make them so
enormous ly big and they fail every
single year and they keep doing this I
think it disappointed every time that's
what this is and now other people are
like I don't really do anything and then
they're like oh but I had a really
touching birthday when I spent it with
this person you know so if I say a worst
birthday to you does something pop into
the brain the you know I've been racking
my brain it's all smoke about this and
you said I said I don't really I mean
there are so many birthdays were just
like MIT yeah and you're like there's
nobody's ever been super mean to me
after earth day or anything like that
mm-hmm and do you set up expectations
for your set like this coming July
there's life when I turned 50 when I
turned 40 when I turned 13 I turned 21
were they big deals they were not they
weren't other people are like well this
is a big one you're doing you gonna do
for it I'm like
I was at a spinal spot and right I'm
hoping to get some page time you can get
some stage time
yeah that's what I would like for my
birthday but other people in your life
must must must have birthday meets or
make make a bigger deal for your fort
well I am I am currently married yes and
I like to think of it as ongoing and
good egg and we've been and it's been
some time now because I got married when
I was 39 all right so I just figured out
how to have a life
yeah and it's all working out but he has
this birthday that matters but he has
this policy about his birthday it starts
the day he gets his first present and it
goes until he gets his last press holy
[ __ ]
right this send me a while it can be one
mail deliveries is added into this yeah
yeah the fact he sees his mother like
once or twice we're always celebrating
your husband's birth
exactly Andy Ash crafts birthday is July
29th which first three years in a row I
have accidentally done booked with the
road on his birthday and so this year I
was like oh this year for our 10th
wedding anniversary I booked that's like
hey do you wanna go to Toledo no no it
turns out he does not wish to go to
Toledo I worked with Greg Proops when I
was starting out in Lansing a dream come
true come true and I said do you ever
bring your wife you know with you on the
road and he goes yeah I know he goes no
I want her to stay married to me I was
like why would I bring her to Lansing
why would I bring her to do that were
you doing connections in Toledo
no I was doing a festival okay good that
was like some weird Yoder festival that
booked me one night yeah and it was fun
yeah but it was yeah it was fine Kelly
don't reminds me of Portland like about
a dozen years ago really yeah there was
pour over coffee they need help they
need some people can show up but and
they do have winter so Toledo I have
never seen as having much of a
progressive right hip movement however
it's been a decade since I've been there
right and they know dart right it was
nice the people that are there were the
bearded youth movement has finally made
it right to Toledo
so it's
it's cheapest [ __ ] cheapest [ __ ] Detroit
Detroit is getting a little bit of a
hipster
I mean hipster meaning I don't know
bearded youth is a good way to put it
poor people for art who want to work on
their art yeah like as they can afford
to live and afford something yeah you
know you hear all these great stories
about New York City and all the
musicians that came out of the Chelsea
Hotel and you're like the Chelsea Hotel
is a one star hotel that's four hundred
ninety dollars a night now you know you
said a one-star I want it to be attached
to the only locked Park in the whole is
that raw City the Chelsea that Park
attached what Grammer's know am I
thinking Gramercy
I don't Gramercy because I don't think
there's a part it's next to Gotham
comedy club thinking Gramercy Gramercy
Park is locked in the Gramercy Park I've
never been able to see it but is a
statue of John Wilkes Booth's brother
Edmund booth who was a famous
Shakespearean actor also know this stuff
check it so does your husband mind that
you're gone on his birthday
no because his birthday last so long so
long it's okay it's right but I bye but
I've made more effort since yeah right
here's what I have you'll block it off
will you tell your people like hey this
July 29th I'd like to stay here with
January 29th yeah January 20 I've tried
I've put it in I've finally gone to an
electronic this helps it does this
Facebook as does Facebook there where I
don't forget things like I remember I
think was in the 90s I forgot my
sister's birthday and she was genuinely
disappointed a mad at me and I was happy
you had that you were gonna college
right so I felt so bad that I sent her
for a week I sent her birthday cards
that supposedly have been lost in
different in the mail like when they
were each date at different years I like
that fun that was fun you were
backtracking my mother comes from a
family where they lost she lost her
brother at age 21 or 22 or something so
she would always send two birthday cards
to her parents as this weird sorry yar
number two right but it almost would
make this really sad you know she would
always send but it is almost like meant
to be
hey remember John his name was John but
it's like and so it's just it just it
just drums up stuff sometimes right
because you're the youngest of four you
know that everybody just signs
everybody's name oh my god my mind is
like you kid I will send my dad a gift
and my sister were like can I get on
that yeah and I'm like we're old now
yeah what are you doing not only that
they I mean they write the name in the
same handwriting yeah I know from your
siblings John Christy and Todd it's like
mom wrote there and it can even write
their names yeah you do you do a gift
exchange Christmas or a holiday with
your siblings or not that's out now
that's we're done where we when they
started having kids hmm I was like your
kids will get your kids will get gifts
that's tough to keep track of that well
I don't keep track of any of their
birthdays okay none of them and do you
know their names I know I'm not gonna
ask you for them but I I honestly my
best friend's children I sometimes have
no idea yes I lose their names all my
nieces and nephews I know their names my
great nieces and nephews home on some
paw let's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] I got
I had two of them there's four yeah the
other two are my nephew Josiah's kids
and I've only met him a couple of times
because they're they live in Tucson and
yeah whatever that's where my brother
the Evangelist lives so I don't visit to
our interesting brotherly evangelist so
what will happen on this next upcoming
birthday forever Jackie where we were in
October yeah have you you're not gonna
think about it until maybe June what you
know well one of my best birthdays and
II was like it was when I loved hearing
this when we were when we were together
mm-hmm
when we first got together he was like
birthdays are important we're gonna do
something what do you want to do yeah
and so I tried to make up a thing yeah
you know cuz that's what you're doing
yeah you're like okay so I genuinely I
said I would like a cowboy birthday and
so the second time of this podcast
you're talking about cowboys Jackie
still in the Cowboys so we would
horseback riding what is it boys you
love I don't know I died
is it cowboys or is it is it Western
culture it's it's horses yeah I think
it's horses and guns
okay and so we we went horseback riding
yep then we went to the gun range
I had never fired a gun before Wow and
we went and it was loud where's the gun
annoying down Van Nuys okay of course
there's a gun range well there's also
like a really famous gun range downtown
LA this is not famous at all yeah I mean
is it it's a classic la can a strip mall
kind of situation we're indoors indoors
yeah and you go in and there was it's
like a bowling alley where there's a
bucket full of headphones yeah and I
said you guys spray these like their
shoes at the bowling alley and the guy
just looked at me goes nope yeah no and
he also probably said no jokes no gun
ranges are terrible they terrify me
well that's because people have guns
it's [ __ ] scary and the people it's
kind of like people that I'm a dog
person but people that devote their
lives to dogs are always a little off
with humans right and people who work
for gun places are always a little tiny
bit alright I'm from Michigan
okay Reagan militia we love our guns you
guys are out of your minds
we already good uh we got one of those
in northern Wisconsin because I'm from
Muskegon the gun range no the militia
yes I'm sort of militia craziness yeah
they're kind of like somehow able to
just run their own government I guess I
don't know but but the you but the feds
aren't really gonna step in I guess cuz
they're armed and and they're they're
white and there's there's no yeah
they're like well they're not doing that
much trouble you're not doing trub
they're not like causing trouble right
it's just leave Malone but I took my
brothers to a gun range in Vegas one
time I was like let's go shoot machine
guns so we right the one in Vegas will
let you shoot machine guns machine guns
right and it was outside it was indoors
and let me tell you what happened we
walked in we saw someone shooting a
machine gun and we said we don't want to
shoot guns and we went to the pinball
museum much more fun the pinball museum
is awesome that is so cool and I don't
like machine guns I learned yeah I don't
uh I don't necessarily I like to shoot
fake guns is what I'd what does that
mean that means I like to play video
games oh sure okay yeah I like to shoot
fake guns uh Andy gave me a steampunk
awesome steampunk Egon
that he got a tack on right sort of
science fiction yep okay i'ma it's easy
game designer my husband oh so he gets
also he designs this stuff he sees toy
man he loves toys games and makes a
living at it we're the best aunt and
uncle ever right that is cool I'm a girl
bunny and he's got the games
so you went horseback riding you
shotguns and then we barbecued meat that
was that was that was a good birthday
and so that was and I thought you know
we shot these guns well first of all let
me tell you something else about guns I
don't like you gotta load him yeah what
pain in the ass yeah
jamming bullets into a into a cartridge
and turns out when at the end of it they
get really hard to push those bullets in
it does and it's so funny because Annie
was raised his entire he was raised in
central California right like sort of
off the Bay Area but no step and that's
real America right oh it is Orville yeah
it's real America it's a veil yeah and
his entire family both his parents moved
to they lived in the Bay Area and then
but both of their families are from the
same small town in Mississippi and so
they are they're very nice people but
they're also they're just super naive
yeah cuz they get cable and that's it ya
know yeah and they're nice enough people
they're not dumb yeah they're just very
naive and could be sold a buggy ride by
Fox News yeah right and left yep you
just like the elections rigged yes it is
rigged please go - I don't care BBC news
calm or anything I don't care the
Guardian it helps if you if you read and
watch stuff that isn't made for
entertainment well American news is you
know the movie or any televised news etc
stuff like Samantha bee which I know is
entertainment sure and she's all mad at
stuff yeah so but the I I read all of my
news and I'd like to get it where do you
go um I do baby BBC news as you see is
pretty good yeah it's good I like off
offshore mm-hmm because then it isn't
CNN
and all that stuff that also has a TV
show that they're trying to sell the
week is good yeah I get the week the
week I get it it's because it says like
hey the right says this the left says
this and then they're like you decide
right you figure it's almost like
journalism yeah it's almost like they
care about the opinion and these are the
facts that they claim they say that
they're fat yeah
from both sides yeah and then you can
ride sounds like he's full of [ __ ] dude
do the Mississippi relatives have guns
they do oh I was gonna say yeah cuz
auntie's Uncle Joe has a man-sized safe
like like what's-his-face and he
collects Winchester's yeah and so the
first time I went to visit and he was
like Uncle Joe you gotta show Jackie the
gun the gun safes are amazing gun safes
and here's the thing keeps them safe yes
it does and and his two nephews and ruin
and RJ yeah they live with all these
names and dates by the way normally is
not as extensive wasn't dates RJ well
Andrew just joined the Marines about two
years ago and and RJ I think decided to
go to college he was like and my
favorite thing about Andrew is antor
coffee marine good guy that's a really
nice kid he's a good guy and but he
wanted to be a recon marine and he
wanted to learn Arabic and go into the
and and be that guy right grow beard
know people and and then guess what I
don't want to do the ever yeah well so
he goes to basic and he gets out of
basically pick him up down in San Diego
to take him to lunch and I was like so
how did it go how the code did you get
did you get into the into the into the
neuron or a language thing and he goes
and with the hopeless Iturbi he just
goes Mississippi public school system
has not done me an operation [ __ ] it's
like one of the worst it may be the
worst it's up there yeah it's
Wisconsin's getting bad but it's
Mississippi's pretty bad he goes I'm
driving the truck yeah he said it's a
fancy truck truck but I'm driving it
well thank you for his service Randy RJ
whoever was it was Andrew and and I
thank you for your willingness to serve
yeah your God knows what your service is
gonna look like
and so but I like that these willing to
give it a shot right it's great that the
people the people do that and they just
got a nice bonus they don't have to pay
back the California National got all
this [ __ ] money somebody dropped the
ball and gave everybody an extra 15
grand is that what it was 15 grand it
was 15 grand and then but the thing is
is they are all like they're swimming in
asbestos or some sort of [ __ ] right
I mean they're they're in Syria next to
a like a gas thing that's been blown up
on purpose cuz supervillains live right
and so that 15 grand isn't really gonna
make up for mo yeah it's like also if we
have to bribe our servicemen and women
with with bonuses maybe we shouldn't be
going to do that whatever but 15 grand
I'm a tax and pay Democrat go ahead yeah
cuz I was talking to Lori Kilmartin cuz
I let the podcast which is on what
Network Nerdist Nerdist so we were
really we have a lot of competition here
at all things coming okay we're cuz I
dark forest is I don't think I know
that's why I was head fragrant your name
is uh isn't your name on that yes it is
GRC at nerd mail all things come to life
pockets with bill burr al John Efrain
good Jackie right there Esparza
yeah and D dollars so um you can listen
to dork forest on all things comedy
Network or at dork forest calm yep the
iTunes itunes and then the other podcast
is on Nerdist or when what is the name
of that podcast it's called the Jackie
and Laurie show Jackie and Lauren we
just [ __ ] about stand-up comedy I love
it and she was and lately a little bit
of politics just because sure just comes
up yeah and the perspective here's what
happened last December
we've been there's only 40 episodes no
no and I don't I've I've never really
I've known Laurie Kilmartin we've had
parallel careers because they never
booked more than one woman right so so
and she was West Coast and I was Midwest
she's very funny
she's amazing she's writes for Conan
yeah her name's Laurie Kilmartin
and last December she genuinely soon
emailed me she said hey you know I'm you
know that question they asked women
comics whenever they're interviewed for
the paper what's it like being a woman
comic and I was like yes
and she said you want to answer that
[ __ ] question every way for [ __ ]
40 FM so they said oh my god that sounds
hilarious that's great and so that's
what we do okay and I gotta listen to
that yeah I'm gonna get Laurie on this
show as well she said she had a really
bad ninth birthday or something and I
remember her telling me about it oh
that's cool that'd be fun so Jackie
where can everybody find your
information at Jackie Kashian on Twitter
and Instagram and snapchat what's your
what's your favorite one I love it
snapchat you are yeah just because damn
it do I have to [ __ ] get on snapchat
snapchat it's not quite honestly you
don't have to follow me on snapchat it's
not for you yeah it's for me I'm having
good no I mean like am i I don't you to
the worst the world vine is dead today
vine died I
they're all gonna die they're all gonna
die Instagram is already stolen a bunch
of stuff from Def Jam stole that's ass
off right well good for Instagram all if
Instagram would steal that the face
filters cuz genuine it's all I love
those are fun I love you put a weird
mask on me I swipe and I get where I'm
sitting I've already done I did I
snapped the Rolly the CC studio yeah
sure I was like cuz it's always cool to
see backstage in a studio not always
gonna be excited about that even though
I don't nobody work yeah I'm in so
Jackie Keisha calm calm you got two
podcasts you have a live when's this
going up this is gonna go up whenever
you'd like it to it goes up on Thursdays
and we'll pick a Thursday that you like
I'm doing Comedy Works a Denver for the
very first time but next week let's next
week will be tough but we can we'll give
it a shot and happy birthday July 20th
thank you thank you what's yours mine is
September 27th the same as your sister
our our Darla Darla
she was named out our little rascals
there was the only kid my dad got to
name most the most amount of birthdays
are in September as of Christmas and
holiday we're just people make it sweet
sweet love nine months we're just we're
just but we're just rats we know we just
have sex all at the same time think
about that next time you having sex like
five million other people are having sex
the exact same time check occasion thank
you for sharing your birthdays
man happy worst birthday she's she's
sucking her soda pop that's Jackie
Kashian ladies and gentlemen man she you
know podcast ends and she just stays
right here chatting with us because
she's just got these stories up the ass
she's great never knew she was youngest
of six it makes sense most stand-up
comics our youngest of a large family
[Music]
refreshing that she didn't know all her
siblings birthdays do you know your
siblings birthdays do you have siblings
I just have one that's easy
so yeah March 18 people people from
smaller families don't understand that
it's a lot to keep track of with the
bigger family I mean my my friends back
in Michigan get mags I don't always call
them back you want to know why Nate Mike
Marc because by the way those are all
true real names white male names because
I got like nine family members I got a
call back first you always got a call
back your family members first cuz you
love him the most that's Jackie Kashian
she's but she's was in the podcast game
before it was even audio recorders she
used to call it in what the [ __ ] are you
doing good for her good for her
please check her out she'll be at the
comedy works for the first time in
Denver this club is impossible to get
into
she'll be there November 10th 11th 12th
and 13th the same weekend that I'll be
in Erie Pennsylvania I think she wins
that week I mean if the Comedy Works in
Denver but this is such a great club and
very difficult to get into and she she
deserves to be there cuz she's hilarious
so please check out Jackie Kashian com
you can always go to worse birthday com
for every single episode we've ever done
you can press archive and you can see
everyone's birth dates and you can find
your birth date so we can track down
every comics birthday you can yeah I
mean it's all there do I have a
beautiful calendar like I want no but it
but we will but we could and it's very
clear you press archive and it shows in
the title you know but it's gonna be
look random but eventually we will get
worse birthdays and I'm including a leap
day if you have a worst birthday and
it's a leap day email me Michael at
Michael Kosta calm because I will fly
you into Los Angeles with the money from
all things comedy and we will record
that because you just really I just need
someone that was born on a birth on a
bird on a leap day they can speak
English and if you can't speak English I
think we could probably make that work
somehow that would be that would be
hilarious by the way I looked up the
Chelsea Hotel is a two-star is it
actually a two-star it has three and a
half stars on TripAdvisor but it is
eight class know it this is a [ __ ]
two-star I mean the reason I used to
live right on 20th and eight right next
to it and the Chelsea Hotel is it is not
a two three and a half star that just
goes to show how shitty TripAdvisor
users are it is just beat down but I
mean this used to be where Leonard Cohen
wrote as a songs and there's there's
this whole big mural up of of who lived
in Bob Dylan and blah blah blah but now
they can't afford it you know you can't
afford to even do that it's too bad
Manhattan is pushing out the artists
Erin hashtag worst bday pod if you're
gonna tweet to us we love it if you do
leave a rating and a review on iTunes
make sure you leave your Twitter or
Instagram handle in the rating and
review and I will shout you out both on
social media and on this podcast worst
birthday calm I'm Michael Kosta thank
you for listening to the worst birthday
podcast on the all things comedy Network
don't forget to click our Amazon link
love you guys bye
you